[Musique]
samedi dans les journées du patrimoine
en m'invité à les jouer à vieille église
en Yvelines le concert a lieu à 16h
[Musique]
à l'église je serai accompagné par
Francis rouguier qui est titulaire de
l'église des grandes orgues de l'église
Sainte-Geneviève de Versailles et
Lorraine balsage est au violoncelle
c'est une super violoncelliste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un peu tout et vraiment je suis très
attention à jouer aussi bien du
classique Mozart bac Erik Satie et puis
ensuite on va se diversifier je joue
beaucoup de musique de films et ça ça
intéresse ça fait plaisir énormément de
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]